let's get to more Bombshells and more
Fallout from Prince Harry's Memoir
turned Royal burn book
how would your mom feel about your
relationship with your brother now
I think she would be sad Harry actually
talks about seeing mediums and
Clairvoyance to try and communicate with
his mother he talks about driving
through the alma tunnel to try and get
some idea of what happened to his mother
it's very clear that he's not able to
let go of the ghost of his mother he
talks about her continuously
there's a fair amount of drugs marijuana
magic mushrooms cocaine I mean that's
gonna surprise people but important to
acknowledge Harry says he first tried
cocaine at 17 on a hunting trip and
those magic mushrooms he claims it was
at Courtney Cox's house Harry writes he
had a crush on her and quote I wondered
if I'd ever work up the courage to tell
her was there enough tequila in
California to get me that brave I think
it's almost impossible to pick out a
single story that was the most salacious
or shocking I mean certainly high up the
list of wow moments was Harry detailing
how he lost his virginity Harry writes
it was with an older woman in a grassy
field behind a bar other surprises he
joked he needed electric shock therapy
to get Megan's TV sex scenes on suits
out of his head also William and Kate
were big fans of the show I have sauces
close to Prince William who say that he
is his devastated but he's also
incredibly angry at the level of detail
which his brother has shared in this
book but the most disturbing Revelation
Royal expert Katie Nichols says Harry's
Under Fire today for revealing his
so-called kill count in Afghanistan
there are real repercussions to his
comment about taking out 25 Taliban
insurgents treating them like they were
pieces on a chessboard and there has
been a real backlash particularly over
here in the UK and particularly within
the military Community where it is
simply not the dumb thing to brag about
the number of kills he looked somber in
the rain with his black lab just hours
before excerpts of spare out Tuesday
were leaked the 38 year old will appear
on GMA on Monday and on 60 Minutes
Sunday night hell I was probably bigoted
meanwhile we've learned Harry had a
Ghostwriter his name is J.R mowringer he
also ghost wrote Andre agassi's
autobiography open Jr's own Memoir the
Tinder bar was a adapted into a movie
that starred Ben Affleck and was
directed by George Clooney the Oscar
winner who attended Harry and Megan's
wedding is rumored to have introduced
the author to Harry I want
reconciliation but first there needs to
be some accountability